this video was sponsored by le land.
ALL Hail to the Greatest gamer
ON THIS PLANET
Thats right !
It's me! I'm back baby!!
TO PLAY A VIDEO GAME (Felix relax)
YOU GUYS THOUGHT I DON'T PLAY GAMES
WELL THAT'S BEACUSE I'M TOO GOOD AT IT
YALL JUST CRY (Felix what the fuck are you saying please stop screaming)
YOU SHOULD BE THANKING ME
FOR NOT PLAYING GAMES CUZ I'LL RIP YOUR ASS
I'LL RIP YOUR MAMA'S ASS
I'LL RIP YOUR DAD'S ASS
AND NOW I'M GONNA RIP (Um) YOU ALL IN WORMAX
AHHH --- oHHHHHH
you may be familiar with this game before, it has a lot of---
---UHH
similarity to all the games, but it has a lot of new features like:
qUESTS
dIFFERENT ABILITIES--- this game has 3 DIFFERENT SKILLS
bOOSTERS --- you can play MULTIPLIER WITH YOUR FRIENDS (that you dont have-- sorry)
RaTiNgS ---  META GAME ARTIFACTS! HELL YEAH!!!!1!! And,THE BEST PART:
You can select custom skins.
That's supposed to be me? hell Yeah. Hey it's got the brofist!
*giggles*
Oh
I don't-- I don't think this is me, but it's cute so I'm gonna go with it :D
I MEAN I'M THE BEST GODDAMN (What ;;) ALIVE!1111! I'M GONNA TAKE OVER THIS PLANET BRO!!!!!!!1
Hell yeah, so now I have this skill. Which does what what it's to boost, okay? Cool.
*Music stops*
And Then later on I unlock new skills
WE ARE GOING TO NUMBER ONE!!!!! I AINT STOPPIN UNTIL THE PEWDS IS PASSED POPPEN (Felix what the hell)
bOi
number one! go-go NUMBER ONEEEEE
Fuck I just lost everything what happened there?
oH
mINE
MiNE *evil laugh*
No, no!
Ok so now we have two more skills
I can stop. I'm going to guess what that one does, I'm not going to try it right now
and then yeeee- I can probably go through other people, but PRRREAAA
SUCK A DICK PENGUIN
Sorry! I take this game way too seriously.
IM KILLING IT
I AM KILLING IT AT THIS GAME!
I was BORN TO PLAY THIS GAME
I AM THIS GAME! -- I am the one the way to tun (??) DONT NEED A GUN TO GET RECPECT UPON THE STREET
Get out of my way get out of my goddamn way. die! That's RIGHT! no mercY!!!!
ANOTHER ONE
49 We go in for number ONEEEEE
"PEWDIEPIE DOESN'T PLAY GAMES!"
tHAT'S BEACUSE I'M TOO GOOD AT IT
I'M TOO GODDAMN GOOD AT IT
I was born inside a-- stop. YOU FUCKING PIECE OF SH---
*sad music r.i.p pewds*
That's ok- that's a minor inconvenience. We will get back to the top. We can also play that game
PRRRRREEEAAA
SUCK MY SNAKE -- SUCK IT
Hey, wait a minute that guy has my skin!
Well, it's not really me is it? BUT whatever
PPPPRRREEEAAAA--Fuck
A Small Setback
don't you worry! We are going to number one no matter what!
OKAY
So there's items in the game as well-- wHOA look at that BOI
HELL YEAH MEN
Can I get another one of those pLEASE?
To be honest
This is Hella tight, man,
I Need to start using my skills. I think that's the problem.
Oh, you just got oUtPlAyEd well I'M SO SORRY
THE HELL DID U JUST DO?
OH NO, y'all gets UNPLAYED
WHAT'S UP
I now respect-- *Weird noise* (Goodbye people I can't do this anymore I hope that I helped :) )
NO. OH you try to do it fast make on me the greatest message
They're gonna promise, whoo. Oh
Shit look at that dog what the hell in it? Oh, what was that boy? Oh, no, you got trapped no?
No, he got fred someone do something
No
No, please oh, it's a tragedy. Oh, no. He got crap oh, no
Oh, no, you can't do that. You can't do that boss
No now, why they hit stop ha ha doctor. Yes, fuck
It's so desperate oh my God. It's a goddamn
Some goddamn warfare out there. Oh my God
I am now on
Xbox sick
Hi, guys, would you guys like to get eat then?
triple feeding
That's right. You live inside me now
You live inside me. Oh
You think you're Gonna live?
Alright will cute. Oh, let's go. Yeah
Brah triple, what happened here? Oh
No, I let one escape
I'll wait they all died oh
No, jun. Do not jun do judo just end your life, please
Ain't got time for it jun. De. There's no way out
Judo just stopped
Jindo please
Jindo come on man. You're being a super lame right now Jindo
now Joe
you know
The way out and now you know not beautiful dudu just nG life
the vegetation, thanks Rick
You know you know come on being a super lame right now even though
ah
King more like suck my ass
Got'em goddamn, this is intense. Oh my God. Yes
This is awesome. Yeah, more power
unlimited Bow
Oh, no, you got friends. No. No is that Rare I?
am the one dangerous dangerous
Well, I use the ability I use the ability that are the mega nice
kick
You can hit stop and you will stop immediately. It's the youthful ability oh
My God everyone is dying
Everyone died ha ha ha ha ha ha
Sorry, sorry guys these are all my babies
Oh, they keep coming. How was that? What are they doing? Oh, no?
They keep dying on me. What are they doing?
seventeen baby
You just got friends in the Pootie plant
That's right boy. It means it means that what did you go to pisa and suck my feet. Oh yeah boy
Yeah
Oh, no, buddy, you did get?
What what how?
Yes, give me all these rewards, okay?
All right, I'm Gonna have to change in
to my Pewdiepie skin
Boy you too. Oh my God out laid out blade mother out out played
you've all been outplayed sons of
Becak
outplayed I
am a snake I am a snake, I am a
Goddamn Snake I
Am a snake I am oh god, I'm getting trapped. I'm getting crap. I'm getting truck. Oh
No, oh, no, you made an oopsie. Oh, oh
Then your plea
They'd not talk don't kill me. I like they owe
I have returned
There is only one hope for me let
to ever become number one
Help me pierce. Help me get to number one that's right everyone in this game. You can buy artifacts
choose an artifact to Buy
I will buy the radioactive thing which does so that if they attack me if I die they can't grow any more
Wow, did you know that Piers Morgan?
Wow
I must kill at least Pierce Morgan
For no reason ever find me oh, I see I see you on the map. Hey, right hello
Yeah, you could technically just feed me. Thank you
Right yeah, I'll see you feed me pic. Please feed me
Feed me pierce you should oh wow what are you doing? Is that's me careful. Wow, okay like a golden dragon
Hey
That's crime here
You crazy